it was a sad day actually when we found  out that cabinet of ministers refused to  continue with association agreement with  European Union cuz i lashed or at the  summer glove nash the price for you to  my reasoning abilities it was about  integrated not to the European Union  itself maybe but to this this room of  the European values yet clove facebook  or video store TCG millet tenure of his  bharat mata stewardship lamar be  regarded ya basta bola busy nishikido  allapattah most a varnan wats guillotine  a wolf's ah geez Nick pretty haha Daria  Maidana revoluta dance to esta para la  mian Breslow ocean menahga innova elites  Ukraine cannot be anything except  democracy so I mean it's not a country  which can be ruled by one party and  controlled by one dictator